هذا هو الشيف تشادويك بويد ،
إنه خبير في إعداد
وجبات لذيذة باستخدام
جميع أنواع الأشياء في المطبخ
ولديه وصفة بسيطة يمكنك من خلالها إعداد
مجموعة من الطرق المختلفة للمساعدة في استخدام كل
هذا الطعام في
الفريزر وتلك التوابل في مخزنك  قبل أن
يصبحوا سيئين ،
أسمي هذا ، اخترت مغامرتك الخاصة
بيلاف ، يمكنك بشكل أساسي استخدام
أي نوع من توابل البروتين أو الحبوب مثل
دجاج الروبيان حتى التوفو المعتمد على النبات
وبعض أرز الكينوا أو حتى المعكرونة
قليلاً من مرق الدجاج أو
الخضار
يعمل بعد ذلك  أيًا كان المطبخ أو نوع
النكهات التي تشعر بها
أنك تقدم مكسيكي شرق أوسطي إيطالي ،
لذا في غضون 25 دقيقة لدينا وجبة جاهزة
باستخدام الفريزر
الخاص بنا ومخزن المؤن الخاص بنا لنطبخ
[موسيقى]
لقد تم تقشير قاعدتي وسأقوم
بذلك  أنهي هذا
مع بعض طماطم الكرز الطازجة الناضجة
التي تناولتها على المنضدة
وأضف بعضًا من البصل الأخضر الطازج
إلى هذا اللون ، ثم تناول بعض
الأعشاب الطازجة التي تناولت معها بعض إكليل الجبل
في الحديقة ،
موسمها قليلًا.  تسخين مسحوق الفلفل
الحار وقليلًا من الملح المصنوع بالكامل
من المخزن لم أضطر حتى إلى
مغادرة المنزل ،
وهناك أيضًا بعض مواقع الويب والتطبيقات
لمساعدتك على طهي فائق يتيح لك
إدخال الطعام الذي لديك
ثم  يبحث في مواقع الطهي
للعثور على وصفات تتناسب مع
مكوناتك ، يحتوي الفرن الكبير على أفكار رائعة لوجبة معينة
قد ترغب
في إعدادها ويساعدك على استخدام كل تلك الأطعمة المتبقية ،
تحتوي جميع الوصفات على عنصر وسائط اجتماعية
يتيح للمستخدمين مشاركة أفكار الوصفات والتعليقات
والتحقق من المخزن  يتيح لك إدخال
عناصر طعامك أو مسح الرمز الشريطي ضوئيًا
وسوف ينبهك عندما
تقترب من هذا الاستخدام حسب التاريخ